how does notice do their due diligence
on their there are what are some of the
things they can do to research who that
niche is that there's something to well
you know there's so many free resources
out there right now if you're you know a
lot of your a lot of your audience or
filmmakers right so the first thing that
your filmmakers should do is you should
go to should go to the numbers comm
which is the - numbers calm and go to
box-office guru and Box Office Mojo and
find movies that are just like yours
that were made in the past five years
I'd say I call these comps this is what
you do when you're a buyer you know I've
been on the distribution side and the
buyer side and the studio side a lot so
whenever we evaluate a movie that we
evaluate it by looking at comparatives
or comps and your film makers should do
exactly the same thing that's exactly
what independent filmmakers should do
independent filmmakers have to start
thinking like buyers or distributors
because ultimately that's how they're
gonna get their work out there so what
you want to do is you want to find comps
and a cop is a movie that is made in the
past 5 years older than 5 years ago it
doesn't matter that market is a
generational it has to be the same genre
it has to be the same rating the same
language the same budget the same level
of star talent so for example if if we
have a romantic comedy with like you and
me starring and try to compare it to a
movie with Kate Hudson and Ben Stiller
it's not a cop because they're movie
stars and you should be able to star but
you know but we're not movie stars so
but if you're gonna have a romantic
comedy and you can compare it to another
romantic comedy that might be made for
$100,000 without name stars with great
actors but without name stars then
you're beginning to find some cops and I
always counsel filmmakers you've got to
find at least five comps true cops
cops don't kid yourself be be brutally
honest with yourself five cops in the
past five years if you can't find five
cops in the past five years you probably
are going to find it very difficult to
get distribution for your mother if you
can find five in the past five years
that have gone out to the marketplace
that have found an audience that have
made a little bit of money you actually
stand a pretty good chance of being able
to get your movie distributed somehow
you